today's topic charles barkley so these
were during a broadcast they were
talking about politics these are
basketball endless hall of famers
charles barkley
i think uh kenny who's not a hall of
famer and i think shaq normally
and it's uh basically one of the best
and i feel like halftime shows they do
great like post game shows for the nba
and uh sometimes they delve into all
kinds of topics so here's what happened
shared that news how painful it was yeah
but the one thing i took out of that
piece
was man i think most white people
and black people are great people i
really believe that in my heart
but i think our system is set up for our
politicians whether they're republicans
or democrats
are designed to make us not like each
other so they can keep
their grasp of money and power they
divide
and conquer i truly believe in my heart
most white people and black people are
awesome people
but we're so stupid following our
politicians whether they're republicans
or democrats
and their only job is hey let's make
these people not like each other
we don't live in their neighborhoods
we're all got money
let's make the whites and blacks not
like like each other
let's make rich people and poor people
not like each other
uh let's let's scramble the middle class
i
truly believe that in my heart
that video made a whole bunch of waves
so preach what are your thoughts
i agree there was a point in time where
politics
was not all throughout the 60s 70s young
people were not engaging in politics
right now with the time that people are
engaging the most in politics
and politics and they need that they
need that to make a gap to make them
it is something it is something that the
i believe that is something that they
use
i remember uh was it uh
a uh body ventura who used to be a
wrestler
and then he went into politics and when
he got out of there it was like yo
this thing is exactly like wrestling no
just adventure
jesse ventura it's exactly like
wrestling
on when the camera is on bat bat boom
boom
when we back they're changing we're like
all homies and everything and stuff
that's what he is
that's exactly what it is and i believe
that's what they polarize
things and it benefits them to for
people to be polarized to
be super fans left and right and this
and that
and most people i believe that all in
all of that scramble
if people could shut up and listen to
each other
they have a lot in common and sometimes
oftentimes want the same thing
this is my money it's really what's
going to be different
is the the money that you make
but if you separate the middle class
make the rich one okay you rich you
don't have now we need to scramble these
we don't need to separate these people
so whatever they vote for
they move for this it benefits us i
think that's what happens
i really think that's what happening
yeah if you poll people whether
republican or democrats
left right on most major issues there's
quite a lot of overlap whether it become
like
you know healthcare minimum wage
a lot of these like different concepts
like there's actually a
vast majority of people on both sides
who agree on a lot of these topics
um and so it's always interesting when
you see like politics
to his neck it's like hmm where's that
coming from and this is completely
anecdotal but in my personal experience
whether i go to red states where i go to
blue states generally most of the people
i meet are
and cool you know it's really once you
get online and people start talking
about their political teams that it gets
very vicious
and you know there's been so much
pressure on us uh you know ever since we
started doing online to pick a team
all you guys are fence sitters or maybe
maybe we just don't subscribe to one
political ideology all throughout
and we don't agree with every single one
of the ideas and i've always said that
i've leaned more left than i do right
but you know like i said they're certain
my views yeah they do lean right
you know and people say like oh that's
cause you're a grifter or maybe
maybe i just have views that don't align
with you
now you gotta pick abba here's a good
example you know i mean you know
black folks generally vote left but a
lot of their social values are super
conservative
are they grifters or due to history
religion
all kinds of different aspects is their
experience very nuanced
so you know i i feel like the way that
the sims is built is like you pick a
team you stick with that team you stay
loyal to that team and you always
on the other team
it's always a democrat's fault it's
always the liberals it's always the
the conservatives it's it's always that
kind of talk that you see online that
permeates
and to agree with the other side is to
be ostracized from your tribe so
uh oftentimes when i see these in
conversation i'm just like oh and i
think it
it does us a disservice because it makes
us very suspicious of our neighbors
i've seen families being broken apart
because who people vote for
yeah that's crazy yeah imagine being so
tribal that you leave the most intimate
tribe that you have
yep that's life that's life
and so yeah when it comes to these
matters i do think
uh it's purposefully done because it's
good for ratings i mean
you know look at trump's now out of
office look at a lot of these news
companies and what
how much their ratings get without
struggle they don't make their
money it is profitable for them to
elect somebody who is very polarizing
because polarized people are constantly
looking for information and things to
echo what they're feeling on the inside
so they dig up dirt
i agree i agree i agree my experience
anecdotally
and i think what a lot of like surveys
have showed is like most of us agree
like cannabis is a perfect example
how is it that it's not legal in most
areas despite the fact that vast
majority of people
have voted for it to be legalized
politicians want us at each other's neck
they don't want us to have what we want
so there's always problems with the
system of course but
uh yeah my general opinion is like i
think a lot of people are
most people are vastly good people and
that's been my experience traveling
what's one of your favorite uh
basketball teams um probably
say i don't really have a favorite
basketball team
okay i got players i like but i said
good
well you're not a real fan you're not a
real fan
but they treat politics like like sports
it's kind of true
i'm not a real fan but it's a sports
hater but it treats they treat politics
like it's a sport
if example you vote for a team
you cannot oh no that other person
i can't stand that person that other
person that actually he's trash
he's this he's dead and you
acknowledging that dave's talent in that
other team
doesn't make you a real fan so you're
not really
on a blue or red whatever if you can see
no that other side has a point sometimes
in politics often times like they debate
and they disagree just because it's on
the other side
because the other side said it no i
gotta disagree
just to prove my people that they're
wrong and
i gotta get i gotta show more it's just
that
they are it's theater that's what it is
it's exactly like wrestling yeah i'm
inclined to agree
so yeah i mean those are my general
thoughts on the matter the other day
like i said
i think most folks are pretty cool so i
got nothing bad to say but let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below do you guys agree with charles
barkley or not
we want to hear from you guys
[Music]
me